what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel um today
i'm on a run where i was now i started
walking um and sometimes i'll have like
thoughts on these runs of just about
like stuff i talk about on my youtube
channel or just like
stuff about my life and i get excited
and i just want to like share it with
you guys
oh gosh okay
so what i wanted to talk about today is
why
if you can it's better to take advice
from people in your actual life than
people on the internet
because the problem with people on the
internet
is they have every incentive to lie to
you and this is coming from like
someone who gives advice
two people
off the internet
like
if you're selling like a
self-improvement course or like a life
coaching any of that stuff like you have
every incentive to lie
because it's gonna sell you
more
like courses more books if you've known
someone for a long time you know what
their life looks like you know what
their strengths are you know what their
weaknesses are you're never going to
know that with me or any other life
coach
and i do think the internet's important
and good because you know there are some
people that don't have good people in
their life to get advice from
and
i'm not saying
that there's no you know good life
courses and no good life coaches on
there you know jordan peterson he
changed my life and put a lot of things
into perspective but
nobody's impacted my life more than my
immediate family and friends nobody
nobody on the internet nobody in the
world
and
at least with your immediate family and
friends you know why they give you the
advice they do and you know
whether it's good or not like if i have
a friend that's been single in dead-end
relationships giving advice
to me i know that so i can take what she
says with a grain of salt but
you you have no idea what people on the
internet what the relationship history
is like you have no idea what the
relationships look like
and
you know i think there's a place for it
i think
it's good that it's there
but
if you can i i really would recommend
people talk to people and their
immediate like friends
and
family
because i know it's tempting like you
see people on the internet and you
really don't see like
100 of them
and what i mean by that is like you guys
i talk to you guys all the time
like
you you hear me talking and i do think
you guys know a side of me but you have
no idea like
what i do
with 90 of my time
uh well you might with some people that
are like streamers but
you guys get what i'm saying i hope
who knows right i'm just talking to a
camera
but
anyways that's that's really my thought
today
is if you can take advice from people in
the in your close immediate friends and
family because one
you know that's that's going to build
your relationship that's going to make
you guys closer and two
you know at least you know where the
information is coming from
and if they're a good source so let me
know in the comments if you guys agree
or disagree don't forget to subscribe to
the channel bring that notification bell
and i'll talk to you guys next time